while police departments around the
country are springing child rapists from
the slammer law enforcement is turning a
decidedly less lenient eye on another
group of miscreants Christian pastors we
will examine why preachers are getting
arrested while the criminals run free
then everyone from politicians to
grocery store workers are jumping to
take advantage of this pandemic we'll
take a look at ethics in times of plague
finally Joe Biden remember him he is
running for president he just launched a
podcast and much like the entire
mainstream media he refuses to mention
the me2 allegations against him all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you know this pandemic has done pretty
strange things to our criminal justice
system or our criminal injustice system
if you prefer we talked yesterday about
New York letting child rapists out of
jail because they think that's going to
slow the spread of the virus
for some reason they let 50 criminals
out of jail in New York and of them
eight or nine were sex offenders and of
them three were child sex offenders who
were rated level three the most likely
to reoffended coincidentally the least
likely to respect social distancing so
they let them out of jail that was a
little strange didn't make a lot of
sense you remember we talked now
probably weeks ago about Philly not
arresting criminals anymore so
Philadelphia if you commit burglary
vandalism if you're a pimp if you're a
fraud stirrer if you're if you steal a
car if you do any of these things you
will not be arrested even if the officer
sees you in the act he won't arrest you
in Philadelphia right now so that's
pretty strange seems a little bit a
little bit backwards now
there's a federal judge who's getting in
on the jailbreak this is being reported
by BuzzFeed news US District Court Judge
John Jones the third is mandating the
immediate release of ten illegal aliens
currently in ice custody so now you can
add to the list child rapists vandals
burglars car thieves fraudsters pimps
and now illegal aliens they get to roam
free but you in the general public have
to lock yourself up in your home doesn't
says that's weird enough it gets even
worse the the question of what to do
with the illegal immigrants and foreign
nationals who are currently in the
country and who are currently detained
by ice is a strange one so this guy
Johnny Jones the third he was appointed
by George W Bush who's appointed by a
Republican president but don't forget
George W Bush was his favor of amnesty
and legalization of
of illegal aliens just about anybody
this this judge said it would be
barbaric to keep these ten illegal
aliens in custody during during the
pandemic
why because they've got chronic
conditions so they've got underlying
health conditions and if the coronavirus
should make it to these jails then
there's a chance that they would suffer
consequences from that again it's not
even the case that it would be likely
that they would die from it or that they
would be seriously affected but there's
a better chance than among the general
population so better to release the
illegal aliens in to the general public
this does raise a question for most of
us who are maybe a little bit more
reasonable than US federal judges why
don't we release them back into their
own countries they are foreign nationals
they broke our laws and are here
illegally
we caught them doing it it is against
the law we have them in custody
why don't we release them back to the
place where the law says we're supposed
to send them their own countries why do
we release them here why do we permit
them and encourage them to continue
breaking the law here during a pandemic
doesn't make a lot of sense we're all
quarantine ourselves because walls work
because we're supposed to socially
distance well how about we socially
distance from the foreign nationals who
break our laws that's a great question
thank you Michael okay we'll get into
why that is and how actually the
criminal justice system is even more
perverse during this pandemic but first
I've got to thank our friends over at
Rock Auto when your car has a problem
you're not afraid of spending
significantly more money for the same
parts you don't mind finding the time to
go into a dealership with a friend so
you can drop off your car and wait for
its turn to be fixed right wrong April
Fool's I know you're better than that
you like a good deal and you would
rather get it done yourself you don't
want to get ripped off by one of these
brick-and-mortar guys and luckily Rock
dot Rock Auto comm can do that for you
The Rock auto catalog is unique it is
remarkably easy to navigate rockauto.com
has everything from engine control
modules and brake parts
two tail lamps motor oil and even new
carpet whether it's for your classic of
your daily driver you get everything you
need in a few easy clicks I love these
guys I don't know anything about cars
and they make it easy for me to navigate
so you got to check it out why would you
ever want to spend up to twice as much
for the same parts go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck right Knowles
Canada wles
in there how did you hear about us box
and that way they will know that we sent
you I wish that this were an April
Fool's joke
the spring in the criminals in New York
spring in the criminals in Philly spring
the illegal aliens on the federal level
I wish that were in April Fool's joke
but it is not and it raises a question
we're gonna release these ten illegal
aliens because they have underlying
health conditions and therefore they
have a statistically higher chance of
being negatively affected if coronavirus
enters that Jail which again no evidence
that it has or even that it will in New
York when they release those criminals
there was no evidence that anyone in the
jail actually had coronavirus but it
raises this question there are 38,000
illegal aliens currently being detained
by ice what do we do with them 10 okay
that's a good start but presumably more
than ten of them have some health
conditions right we're just gonna let
all of them out into the general public
why can't ice be permitted to do its job
and return foreign nationals to the
countries that they are citizens of
there's a real irony here that that
while we're all being told to hunker
down in our homes and we can't leave and
we can only go after essential
activities we can barely make it to the
supermarket without a cop looking at you
funny well we're all being told to do
that criminals all around the country
are being sprung from their jail cells
this seems a little bit backwards but
the police are not going easy on
everybody okay they're going to light on
the child rapists and everybody else but
there is one group that the police are
not going easy on and that would be
Christian pastors yes that nefarious
cabal
of Christian pastors that cops are
clamping down hard on them in Florida
Tampa police officers just arrested mega
church pastor rodney howard-browne that
was on Monday because he refused to
close his church doors the day prior
they charged pastor Howard Brown with
unlawful assembly and violating public
health emergency rules
so unlike the child rapists they decided
they were going to take in pastor Howard
Brown now luckily like the child rapists
they allowed this pastor to leave
eventually but unlike the child rapists
again they forced this guy to pay a $500
bond so if you are a Christian pastor
holding a church service you'll be
arrested you have to you have to post
bond if in certain areas of New York you
rape a child no big deal that let you go
to the Holiday Inn they actually sent
these people to the Holiday Inn not just
Florida that's doing this Louisiana
police in Central Louisiana arrested
another pastor Tony spell of life
Tabernacle Church it was the same crime
pastor spell had the audacity to hold
church services and they issued him a
misdemeanor summons for six counts six
counts being the number of times that he
has held church services since the
Democratic governor of that state
ordered him not to now the the act of it
is outrageous enough but but the
craziest part of this story is the
hysteria with which the police chief has
responded central police chief Roger
Corcoran says that he coordinated quote
with the sheriff State Police State Fire
Marshal and others to nab this Christian
pastor you know it's a wonder that he
didn't call in the National Guard he
could have called an Interpol to try to
track down this pastor who told everyone
exactly where he was preaching and what
he was doing for that horrible crime of
spreading the gospel the police chief
said mr. spell will have his
in court where he will be held
responsible for his reckless and
irresponsible decisions that endanger
the health of his congregation and our
community that's that's how he fumed he
was furious but they got him they got
their man this has gone too far
public health crises public crises in
general but specifically the ones that
regard health and questions of life and
death
offer demagogues a lot of opportunity to
steal more power for themselves that's
just how it works andrew Cuomo said if
what we have done saves even one life
then it was all worth it of course that
line didn't make any sense because if
shutting down the global economy saves
one life from coronavirus how many lives
is it going to end from suicide despair
opioid overdose of not being able to
access normal services that you're gonna
access how many lives you can't how
could you even make that calculation but
Cuomo's line makes a lot of sense if
you're a politician if everything we've
done saves just one life then it was
worth it yeah of course it is because
it's a win-win for the politician if he
saves one life that's a good thing even
if he doesn't save any lives he will
leave this crisis more powerful than he
started it that's true of all the
politicians here they have it so much
more power now they have so much power
that they're they're just flaunting it
when you were releasing child rapists
and arresting Christian pastors you were
flaunting your power you know there's a
rule in medicine and in politics we've
talked about it the last few days you
don't want the cure to be worse than the
disease when child rapists are walking
free and pastors are behind bars
the cure is officially worse than the
disease that cannot go on lots of
demagogues here trying to take advantage
of this virus and because they all do it
in the name of Public Health then we let
them get away with it we don't even
question but there are a lot of people
trying to take advantage I give you an
example in Washington Ilhan
Bernie Sanders AOC they've now signed a
letter they are calling for an end to
American sanctions on Iran Iran the
largest state sponsor of terror in the
world have killed many of our soldiers
over the last couple of decades and even
before that we have sanctions on them
they're a terrorist regime they are not
abiding by the rules that we've all
agreed to in the international community
they got one foot in the international
community one foot out of it so we have
sanctions on them and these guys Ilhan
Omar Bernie and AOC are apologists for
the mullah regime they they love Iran
they they want to normalize relations
with Iran so they're calling for an end
to sanctions what does American foreign
policy in Iran dating back to the 1970s
have to do with coronavirus the only
thing it has to do with it is that
people in Iran also have coronavirus and
that's very sad when the Iranian people
have coronavirus some people in the
regime have coronavirus too that's a lot
less sad that's what if we're talking
about problems and solutions that's a
little bit of a tougher calculation to
make but but these three demagogues are
jumping on this they're saying it's so
oh the mullahs the mullahs are getting
coronavirus we need to forgive them for
killing American soldiers for decades
and just let them have a lot of money
send the pallets of cash give them the
nuclear bomb I don't know what I don't
know that's right they're not calling
for that right now they're just going
through the lifting of sanctions has
nothing to do with it you know we saw
this with Nancy Pelosi held up the
coronavirus relief bill because she said
we needed to we needed to stop the
airlines from polluting as much the hell
does that have to do with coronavirus
nothing but it gives them a good
opportunity to amass more power for
themselves the Kennedy Center speaking
of Nancy Pelosi she shoved this bit of
pork into the coronavirus relief bill
Kennedy Center got millions and millions
tens of millions of dollars 25 25
million dollar bailout from the relief
package and the whole idea was we've got
a bailout the Kennedy Center so that
they don't fire their musicians so what
it can be Center do hours after they got
their money in the stimulus bill you can
probably guess they fired their
musicians hours
that's taking advantage of the crisis
that's deceiving the American people
that's getting all that money sitting
for more fancy parties but firing
musicians because is they don't need
them right now they're not holding
public performances well that's fine we
don't need to give them 25 million
dollars either and there are people now
in Washington who are trying to retro
actively go back and take that money
away from them but it's actually not
even just our political and cultural
elite that are getting in on the
opportunism I didn't expect to be saying
this but even Whole Foods workers are
trying to take advantage of the pandemic
Whole Foods the grocery store it's like
the fancy grocery store
Whole Foods workers are going on strike
they're not even really going on strike
it's not like a formal strike they're
going on a sick-out they're all calling
in sick and that all I'm sure some
people are still showing up to work but
that's what's happening right now is a
matter of the labor movement at Whole
Foods what do they want they want
protective gear to take care of their
health and the epidemic and they want a
pay raise significant pay raise they
want double their pay now part of this
is reasonable order this is unreasonable
having protective masks when you're one
of the few businesses that's still open
yeah I guess that's reasonable totally
fair Whole Foods workers should be able
to get as many masks as they want just
like all the grocery store workers
because grocery store workers have been
have been pretty heroic here you know
they are they're one of the few
industries that has to show up for work
that's working with this kind of
craziness and panic and long lines to
get in and buy everyone's buying the
toilet paper and they're out there so
they're risking more exposure to the
virus so I'm immensely grateful to them
you know after health care workers
they're probably the most overworked and
undervalued people in this whole
pandemic but that does not give them the
right to take advantage of this crisis
right now okay first of all we're
looking at something like 5 to 6 million
Americans who could be unemployed within
a week insane
numbers of unprecedented numbers of
Americans unemployed so if you have the
opportunity to work right now you should
be grateful for it I don't want to sound
callous and cold but you should a lot of
people are losing their jobs a lot of
people would love the opportunity to
work right now even the people who do
have their jobs are taking pay cuts
virtually everybody I know who is still
working has taken a pay cut and some
people have just been laid off
altogether so if you have the
opportunity to work and to keep all your
pay you're doing very well ok good like
thank you you're doing a good job also
you should be grateful for that
opportunity now is not the time for
workers in any industry to be haggling
for a raise especially a raise of 100%
because you could make the argument well
look they're just worried that they
might get sick
sure yeah if they're gonna get sick then
they should be able to get the masks
which they're getting they should be or
which they should be getting at least I
think they're getting them they should
be able to get workers comp they can get
that if they're unable to work and the
workers comp is run out they should be
able to get a good unemployment benefit
well they can we know that we just got a
huge stimulus package through give give
people a $600 raise anyway so in many
places you can make more money on
unemployment than you could make before
unemployment you get that you get a lot
of things right we've actually done a
fairly decent job at the federal level
of taking care of workers in all of this
but the fear here doesn't just seem to
be about health the fear here seems to
be that's not even a fear it's just an
opportunity to make more money but while
every other American is sacrificing and
losing their money that's not the time
to do it it raises a question what
should whole foods do with these
employees and one example that comes to
mind is the old Gipper Ronald Reagan who
back in the 1980s uh in a different
circumstance he had federal workers the
air traffic controllers who went on
strike this was in violation of the law
so it's different than the grocery
workers who are not violating the law
but it was in violation of the law and
people just expected Reagan to totally
give in give in to whatever demands they
had and instead he fired them all that I
tell those who failed a report for duty
that this morning they are in violation
of the law and if they do not report for
work within 48 hours they have forfeited
their jobs and will be terminated and a
statement
[Music]
what lesser action can there be the law
is very explicit
they have violating the law I love
Reagan I just love what what lesser
action can there be I'm gonna fire them
and they they better show up to work
dagnabbit
so obviously this is not a perfect
analogy here because the air traffic
controllers were federal employees they
were not permitted to strike it was
against the law and Reagan did
absolutely what he should have done and
fired them in the case of the grocery
store workers that is not the case they
have every right to strike however they
might remember that we are in the midst
of an unprecedented national and global
crisis and looking back on this I don't
think that they're going to I don't
think they're gonna want to be
remembered for squeezing an extra 10
bucks or 15 bucks or whatever you know
based on the local regulations in
different cities I don't think they're
gonna want to be remembered for
squeezing a few extra dollars out of
their employer during this epidemic I
think they'll probably want to be
remembered for solidarity and showing up
to work and helping people out and if if
you want to do that then trying to
squeeze a few extra bucks is not exactly
a great look now it's not only them it's
not only it's not only Whole Foods it's
not only AOC it's not only the Kennedy
Center it's not only even elected
Democrats who are trying to seize
opportunity from this crisis Republicans
can occasionally do that too never let a
crisis go to waste
president Trump showed us that yesterday
with the yesterday's press conference
was probably the most information-packed
press conference that we have gotten in
a number of days you know I watched them
every single day beginning to end in
part because they're extremely
entertaining and you all I assume at
this point Jim Acosta is just on the
payroll because he's giving so many
opportunities for Trump to just dunk on
the press and it's very enjoyable to
watch but sometimes they're more
informative than others yesterday was
one of those times there was a lot of
new information here about the pandemic
about the government response to the
pandemic and even about a plan for what
happens to get us out of this biological
and economic crisis part of that is
something the president Trump used to
talk about a lot then he stopped talking
about it for a couple years now it's
back on the table and that is a massive
infrastructure bill anticipating the
like after the economic crisis of 2008
2009 America will need to have so-called
shovel ready jobs ready to go to get
people back to work well the problem
with that one is they had maybe
shovel-ready jobs and maybe not but they
never used it for the purpose of
infrastructure so far nobody has been
able to find any money that was spent on
infrastructure I want to use it for
infrastructure and one of the reasons
I'm suggesting it John is who are paying
zero interest the United States is
paying almost zero interest rate the
federal reserve low at the rate the Fed
rate and that and a combination of the
fact that everybody wants to be in the
United States you know we have the
dollar that's very strong and I know
that sounds good but it does make it
hard to manufacture and sell outside
because other currencies are falling in
our currency is very strong it's very
very strong proportionately it's through
the roof so we have a strong dollar
people want to invest in the United
States especially nowadays where they're
looking at safety they have all of the
problems plus the virus at 151 countries
they all want to come into the United
States and so we have a zero interest
rate essentially and I said wouldn't
this be a great time to borrow money at
zero interest rate and really build our
infrastructure like we can do it I'm
having deja vu all over again here this
is starting to look very similar to what
happened after the financial crisis in
2008 I mean just look at the look at the
analogy after the financial crisis we
saw first the Troubled Asset Relief
Program tarp to stabilize the economy to
stabilize the industries that were
really affected and get the system
working again then you had the American
Recovery and Reinvestment Act also known
as the stimulus bill that came later and
that was to give us shovel-ready jobs
and to get people working again and to
address unemployment here you're seeing
a similar thing you have first
the relief bills that went into effect
just week two ago massive 2.2 trillion
dollars that they treat to 1 1 trillion
dollars that they levered up to be about
6 trillion now you're hearing about
addressing unemployment now
the thing to keep in mind here is while
they look very similar right you can see
you can see the same structure and same
process they really are different
situations why are they different well
the last relief package is different
than tarp because tarp was addressing
industries that had their own internal
problems tarp was bailing out people who
acted inappropriately
tarp was bailing out financial
institutions that in many ways dug their
own grave that's why people hated tarp
so much in the case of the last
coronavirus stimulus bill that's not
what happened to Pete the people who
were given relief restaurant workers
right small businesses they didn't do
anything wrong they were told by the
government to shut down not shut down
the global economy and so they needed
some relief for that those are different
in the same way here in Trump is making
this argument an infrastructure bill is
fundamentally different from the bailout
under Barack Obama how is it different
the bailout under Barack Obama the
shovel-ready jobs weren't so shovel
ready they didn't work they didn't
actually bring down the unemployment
rate because they went to a bunch of
nonsense it was a lot of cronyism in
there it was a lot of fat that didn't
actually end up employing people a real
infrastructure bill if we could ever
manage to get that what would not be
quite the same why because if you're
making a stimulus bill and you decide ok
I've got a billion dollars to play with
this just pick a number at random a
billion dollars to play with and you and
you put all that every single penny of
that billion dollars into employing
people and you the way you're gonna
employ people is you're gonna give them
all little sporks little plastic sporks
and tell them to dig holes in the ground
and shovel dirt from here to here right
just and not you're not doing anything
actually productive you're just kind of
keeping people occupied
it's really no different than a handout
right that's really no different than
just writing people a check they're not
doing any actually productive work and
that's not going to have a great effect
on the economy whereas if you were to
take that same amount of money put it
into an infrastructure bill that
actually went to infrastructure that we
need you would help the economy because
we do have crumbling infrastructure in
the United States this has been a
problem now for decades crumbling roads
crumbling bridges just just a shoddy
infrastructure system that needs an
update so if we could manage to take all
of that money and employ people in
actually productive work to fix all of
these things to make our business run
more efficiently to make our economy run
more efficiently when we pull out of
this that would be a very good thing is
it going to turn out that way I'm not so
sure we'll have to wait and see but
regardless of how it actually would turn
out it shows us that Trump is craftier
than a lot of people give him credit for
and certainly craftier than a lot of
Republicans because Trump is taking
Democratic political advice on this
infrastructure bill he's not letting a
crisis go to waste we'll get to how that
is we'll get to the other important
information that came out of this press
conference we'll get to so much more
remember Joe Biden I barely even who is
that guy Joe he's running for president
cuz there's a presidential election
that's right I had I had forgotten well
there's some big nose new big new big
nose big news on Joe Biden oh that is
coming up at first if you haven't had a
chance to see some of our new content
called all-access live you should head
over to daily wire.com and check it out
we will continue all of this week at 8
p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific it's not
even really a show I did one last night
it's just kind of hanging out we just
turned the camera on talk to our
all-access members that's who the show
is intended for but now since we're all
in quarantine and losing our freaking
minds as this goes on at least until
April 30th we wanted to open it up to
all of our members so please let us know
what you think of it if you were around
at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
tonight join us over on the all-access
live show or a daily wire.com and if
you're not a member at all go to daily
wire.com slash subscribe we'll be right
back
Trump is taking the Democratic political
advice here and not letting a crisis go
to waste that's a very good thing
because while the left is doing it to
release criminals which they always want
to do while the left is using it to let
illegal aliens run free which they
always want to do while the left is
doing it to stuff a bunch of
environmentalist proposals into stimulus
packages or try to lift sanctions on
Iran or try to fill the pockets of the
people at the Kennedy Center while they
lay off workers or whatever Trump is
using it to get a bill that he's wanted
for a long time that actually would be
productive for America if it were
properly implemented and that is
infrastructure I encourage him I mean
that's great if everybody else is taking
advantage then the right cannot
unilaterally disarm though ideally we
would reduce the opportunities for
people to take advantage of this crisis
by phasing it out I'm trying to think of
the most diplomatic way to put this
phasing it out it would seem to be that
in many different sectors we're getting
to the place where the cure is worse
than the disease so it's time to start
gearing up again now President Trump
doesn't want to gear back up too quickly
he explains why in the press conference
his main purpose of this press
conference was to prepare Americans for
a terrible two weeks I want every
American to be prepared for the hard
days that lie ahead we're gonna go
through a very tough two weeks and then
hopefully as the experts are predicting
as I think a lot of us are predicting
after having studied it's so hard you're
gonna start seeing some real light at
the end of the tunnel but this is going
to be a very painful very very painful
two weeks when you look and see at night
the kind of death that's been caused by
this invisible enemy it's it's
incredible I was watching last night
governor Murphy of New Jersey say 29
people died today meaning yesterday and
others talking about numbers far greater
but you get to know a state I'm
New Jersey's so well and you need 29
people and hundreds and other locations
hundreds in other states and this is
going to be a rough two-week period so
there's a lot of conflicting information
here Trump is saying it's gonna be a
rough two weeks so two weeks is the time
we got to focus on but then we're also
hearing it's going to be another full
month of lockdown but then we're also
hearing from other people it could be
more than a month we're even hearing
this from doctor foul she would seem to
be implying this so why all of the
confusion here foul she actually
explains why part of the difficulty here
is that deaths lag the illness so you
know the illness spreads but people
don't just die immediately the people
who are going to die get sick the
symptoms worsen they go to the hospital
there and eventually they die so you
could get into a situation where the
pandemic is actually getting much much
better even though the death numbers are
increasing the deaths and the intensive
care and the hospitalization always lag
behind that early indication that there
are less new cases per day the way we
saw in Italy and the way we're likely
seeing I don't want to jump the gun on
it we're seeing little Inklings of this
right now in New York so what we're
gonna see and that's we gotta brace
ourselves in the next several days to a
week or so we're gonna continue to see
things go up we cannot be discouraged by
that because the mitigation is actually
working and will work the slide that dr.
Burke showed where you saw New York and
New Jersey and then the cluster of other
areas our goal which I believe we can
accomplish is to get the hotspot places
the New York's the New Jersey and help
them to get around that curve but as
importantly to prevent those clusters of
areas that have not yet gone to that
spike to prevent them from getting that
spike okay so that makes perfect sense
but the question then becomes their talk
about mitigation what is full mitigation
the question on everybody's mind as
we're considering is the disease is the
Cure worse than the disease is when does
this end
because it's got a real long tail on it
what is full mitigation do we get to
there's gonna be a bad two weeks do we
get to stop after two weeks no with the
president saying we've got to stop we
got to go another two weeks after that
but you're still gonna have deaths at
that point are we gonna just reopen on
April 30th or there's gonna be another
two weeks and another two weeks what dr.
fat she points at is it all relies on
the models but the models are not
necessarily reliable 100,000 is the
number with a full mitigation of how do
you push it so John it's an obvious very
good question if this is full mitigating
mitigation and it's a hundred thousand
why am i standing there saying I want to
make it better because that's what the
model tells you what's going to do what
we do is that every time we get more
data you feed it back in and relook at
the model is the model really telling
you what's actually going on and again I
know my modeling colleagues are going to
not be happy with me but models are as
good as the assumptions you put into
them and as we get more data then you
put it in and that might change so even
though it says according to the model
which is a good model that we're dealing
with this is full mitigation as we get
more data as the week's go by that could
be modified now I really like actually
what dr. fowey said here because the
short version of his answer is yeah we
don't know I don't know how are we
supposed to know but within that answer
what he's saying is we're just working
on models and the models are as good as
the data that you're putting in and the
data we have right now aren't very good
that's how models work they predict they
project into the future but you can't
know the future so very often you see
this with global warming global warming
models have very often been wrong
because
they take a little bit of data and they
extrapolate that data to look 50 a
hundred years into the future but if you
get it just slightly off at the
beginning you end up with wild results
at the end they say well what does full
mitigation look like I don't know
says dr. foul Qi what data do you have
it's changing every single day so I
think that what the reporter is getting
at here is you've got full mitigation
you're going full steam ahead how low
can we get that number and crucially
once we stop the mitigation efforts is
the number just going to jump right back
up again is there going to be a second
wave look about second wave I think you
really are talking about two two
different things that are a little bit
different so for example after the 30
days if we get the mitigation that we
hope will get us to the suppression that
dr. Burks was talking about there's a
danger if we don't continue to maintain
that that will we have a resurgence
right within the current outbreak that's
sort of a second way but it really is a
exacerbation of the current wave so what
do we mean by maintain that after the 30
days see he was hidden in there and
people aren't talking about this as much
but initially we told 15 days to stop
the spread and we're told it's another
30 days to stop the spread so now we're
at 45 days to stop the spread that's 3x
what the federal government told us
initially now we're being told if we
don't maintain that after the 30 days or
45 days total then we could see a second
wave so are we gonna be expected to lock
down after this new 30 days that seems
to be what doctor foul Qi is employing
implying implying very few men I sound
like Joe Biden these days we'll get to
Joe Biden in a second it is going to
have a major effect on how and how many
people employers are employing
at this point I'm feeling fairly
pessimistic about this whole thing right
it's not sounding great it's sounding
like it's going to be a tough two weeks
we're going to have to go through April
thirtieth of a shutdown
then maybe you'll have to go even after
that maybe there's gonna be a second
wave and of course in my pessimism in my
despair Jim Acosta swoops in to make it
even worse is there any fairness to the
criticism that you may have lulled
Americans into a false sense of security
when you were saying things like it's
going to go away what is and that's sort
of thing but Jim is going what when you
were sent Ewing to go away hopefully at
the end of the month and if not it
hopefully will be soon after that but so
just going on this as you're thinking on
this evolved you're taking it more
seriously I think from the beginning my
attitude was that we have to give this
country I know how bad it was all you
have to do is look at what was going on
in China it was devastation and well
yeah look at the numbers from China
those initial numbers coming out from
China but you know I read an article
today which was very interesting they
say we wish president Trump would give
more bad news get badness I'm not about
bad news I want to give people hope I
want to get people a feeling that we all
have a chance of course this is the
right attitude I mean what a dumb
question for Mecosta he's asking the
same question that other reporters have
been badgering Trump about for weeks
which is are you giving people a false
sense of hope and by the way the the
real question underlying that is hey are
you a liar why are you such a liar and
you're telling people lies and you're
saying it's gonna be okay when actually
it's gonna be terrible and there's gonna
be death and destruction all around us
you're a liar a bad question it's Jim
Acosta what do you expect at Trump gave
a good answer you look I'm a bad hope
we're gonna get through this this is the
one thing that actually does give me
some political hope and all of this is
Trump has been good so far he's got a
good track record he's handled this
crisis admirably it's a very difficult
situation he's been put in so that does
give me a little political hope I don't
ground my hope ultimately in politics
but in in so much as there is political
hope that gives me some but it's going
to be a tough two weeks and that's just
a fact of life and we're all gonna have
to deal with it hopefully won't be a
tough month or month and a half or two
months
remember Joe Biden Joe Biden who was he
he was the guy is this guy who gives the
shoulder massages I think right yeah
that's him well nobody's talking about
that one
Joe Biden still running for president I
guess there's still a presidential
election even no one's talking about it
Joe Biden is launching a podcast and
this is really brilliant you know
Charlie Kirk my friend who actually I
just sat down and had a long discussion
with and we'll play a little clip of
that and then the full thing will be out
on Friday there shortly Kirk just
tweeted this out though is pretty
interesting observation he goes it's
been six days since allegations of
sexual assault came out against Joe
Biden the likely Democratic nominee how
many stories have the mainstream media
run on this do you what do you want to
venture a guess give you you're right
the guess you're thinking of you're
right well I shouldn't impose zero New
York Times zero CN n zero MSNBC zero do
you remember a judge justice Kavanaugh
do you remember Christine palazzi four
do you remember how the mode you
remember Michael a Vinod he got a whole
career peddling that trash all baseless
allegations and the mainstream media ran
with it 24/7 now you've got what very
likely is another baseless allegations
but it's far more credible than the
Cavanaugh allegations against Joe Biden
and the mainstream media refused to say
a single word about it so Joe Biden is
releasing a podcast now he doesn't even
have to worry about the mainstream media
going after him but he still can't
handle that because he can't remember
his own name so even friendly interviews
go very very poorly for Joe Biden he
can't allow himself into that venue as
much anymore so he's launching a podcast
this is the perfect venue for Joe Biden
take a little listen to the intro 18
Biden is Joe and I'm sitting here in
Wilmington Delaware and it's a scary
time a lot of people out there
few things are changing every day every
hour so I wanted to have this
conversation with you how good why am I
doing this well first so we can keep
talking with each other and we can't
hold rallies anymore boat we're not
gathering in large public spaces we're
living into new normal but I want you to
know that I'm with you I'm on your side
and we're gonna get through this
together as a country and second reason
is I think this podcast could offer some
really helpful information I've seen
these kinds of crises before and and
I've said The Situation Room in the Oval
Office and we've grappled with crises
from Ebola outbreak to the Iran nuclear
deal to the auto industry rescue and
during that time I've been able to work
with some pretty accomplished experts
wow he seems so much more put together
on that highly produced podcast that he
himself is releasing than he does in the
debates or at his rallies or on
television Wow so strange what a
coincidence the reason this is a great
medium for Joe Biden is because Joe
Biden has never had message discipline
has never had very much political
self-control but especially now that
he's kind of losing his marbles he's got
even less of it so you you can control
the medium and control the message in
podcasting that's why it's good for him
the the thing that they're taking too
far here is that they're trying to make
him sound too good so you can hear
they've sped him up they recorded
whatever they were going to record and
then they just sped it up probably at a
1.1 or maybe even a little bit higher
than that so it's moving faster than he
has ever talked in public the other
thing is they're taking out all the
breaks so all the stumbles all the times
he gets things wrong but even all the
times that he breathes so the thing is
just running so fast there's no air in
it it's very clear that this was was
highly produced that might come back to
bite Joe Biden because it's like the
same reason actors mess up their head
shots you know very often actors let's
say it's a totally bland mediocre
looking actor they'll have a head shot
that's so photoshopped that the person
looks like a supermodel and that's fine
maybe that gets you the audition but
then you show the head shot they say
wait a second that's not you I don't you
don't look like that picture well it's
the same thing with this podcast Joe
Biden they're making him seem so much
quicker so
sharper so much faster that when you
hear that not that anyone's gonna listen
to the show but if people did listen to
the show when you hear them then you
compare that to Joe Biden in real life
you're gonna say wait a second this
isn't the same person so they've got to
be very careful with this
but the Biden campaigns are not careful
so it's probably not gonna happen I
mentioned that I sat down with my friend
Charlie Kirk while we were both in
quarantine we did this for his podcast
and it's released there on audio we're
gonna release it on video though on
Friday so stay tuned for that and here
is just a short clip from our discussion
because you know Charlie and I we love
to we love to debate different aspects
of politics somehow we're both on the
same side we're both on the same team we
do events together all the time and yet
we manage to disagree about a lot of
different subjects and one of them is
the nature of political coalition's and
where the right is moving into the
future here's just a little bit of that
discussion I guess the question is is
the left try I think I know the answer
but is the left trying to loop us all
together because they don't know better
or they or they do they know better and
they're doing intentionally so they can
just have domination you left this
domination basically yeah you know I'd
like to give them the benefit of the
dead because it's early surely is
convenient and helpful to them to lump
us in you know and everybody that to the
right of Hillary Clinton is Hitler and
it makes them easier to shut us up so
there's a real convenience to it but I
do also think in the left's defense that
they simply don't know what we believe
you know there was that study that came
out a few years ago from John Hite who
which showed that while the right
generally understands the left the left
actually does not understand the right
and just anecdotally but don't forget
the anecdote is data you talk to a lot
of leftists and they actually don't know
what you believe they actually don't
understand the arguments that you're
making so it's obviously a little bit of
both but I I will give them credit for
their ignorance I mean look I think I
think some left us know better I think
leftist followers don't and I think that
the leaders do know better they know
where the true hateful lines are drawn
and they know they know
but they don't even police the evil in
their own ranks in fact they endorsed
and tolerated I mean Linda Sarsour who's
an anti-semitic anti Western anti she's
a Jew hater is what she is
she's a debater yeah yeah and I mean
exactly and then she just promoted to be
what spokesman of the comrade Sanders
you know but the Makemake Bolsheviks
great again red line whatever oh she
would go to the women's March and hold
hands with Gloria Steinem the great
feminist what do the hijab and the [ __ ]
hat have in common very little except
they are both opposed to sort of
traditional culture yes and the more you
study the left the more you fight the
left like you brilliantly do you
understand that the left is not they're
not united by truth and they're not
united by values because they the left
truth is not a left-wing value and they
don't actually don't have values they're
united by hatred that's all they have
that's all the left has and so you can
find for example you can find what is
the most you can find why what people
believe in what their nearest and
dearest values are based on what they
build alliances around and so we as
conservatives build alliances around
truth and commonality and goodness and
optimism and love of America right but
the left they build alliances around
hatred they I mean for example you have
with your sorry suing Gloria Steinem if
you sat them in a room together and you
said what are the things that matter to
you most
sorry sewer would probably say
implementation of Sharia law the
abolition of Israel and all sorts of
crazy you know basic you know fun
fundamentalist ideas yeah where Gloria
Steinem would say free abortions on
demand for every single woman you know
always and basically shout abortions
right right precisely and so those
things are at odds and then you add into
there the transgender stuff what i mean
they're they're totally at odds with
each other but what they have in common
is that we're bad they haven't gone in
that the Conservatives and the Americans
and people that want to preserve Western
civilization the Jo Christian ethic they
want to destroy us they want to silence
us they're united by their hatred that's
what drives the left right well you know
though I will say in a word of defense
in the politics of opposition you know
very often having a common foe does
bring disparate groups together so it
like it's a strange thing right it on
the right that there are people who are
TRADD catholic social conservative guys
who wear suits and ties to church every
Sunday and then there and have like 15
kids and there at 25 years old I don't
even know that's possible and then there
are also guys who are atheist homosexual
libertarian you know socially liberal
whatever and yet they do have a coherent
coalition because the common foe right
for both of them is this woke leftist
culture which is kinda silenced both of
them I think the difference though
Michael and I anticipated that
counter-argument from you or for someone
listening to this I would say the
difference though is that person that
might have be totally different than the
the Catholic going Latin Mass ceremony
attending like you that you know wears a
three-piece suit and recites the rosary
backwards in original Aramaic whatever I
gotta work on my Aramaic I guess yeah
yeah that was the language that Jesus
spoke that's true but the difference is
that they actually have a love for
America that's what really unites them
and they consider the let they if you go
a level deeper the left is the greatest
threat to that love though yes we're the
left the left the left doesn't have the
love for the country and all they have
is the hatred all they have is it the
most elemental core of their alliances
between the transgender D
constructionists and the glorious
diamond feminists and the Linda Sarsour
Islamic fundamentalists is that they
actually don't have a commonality of
what they want to exist the commonality
between you're somewhat accurate
depiction that you have the atheist you
know and the Catholic three-piece going
Latin Mass ceremony attending individual
like yourself building a coalition is
that if you actually break it down
actually want in America that has
markets and private property and
constitution yeah and then they find
agreement that the left is the greatest
threat to those things yeah no I think
that's absolutely right and it's so much
you know it's not just us Latin Mass
going Catholics here it's also
evangelicals evangelicals being the most
reliably conservative voter base and I
know you're doing a ton of work in that
area with your with the Falkirk Center
and what do you what do you see moving
forward I mean do you think that we're
gonna have a kind of Christian
resurgence in America or are we going to
fall back to it we have to and I have so
much respect for my Catholic
and you know I'm always kidding yeah
when I say these things you know and we
have fun and I actually do have some
very serious Catholic theological
questions at the end of this all right
lamb are we I'm ready
I would love to have you answer and
they're corona related will I convert
charlie Kirk to Catholicism probably not
but you can listen and get the answer on
Friday we'll release that whole exchange
I think it was about an hour we cover
grown a virus we cover the political
coalition's we cover politics culture
and religion and everything in between
and I always love talking to Charlie you
know we try to that guy's on a plane
every three minutes pretty much and so
now that the quarantine has happened he
is forced to stay in one place it's the
longest time he stayed in one place I
think in about eight years so he called
me up afterwards and said hey I'm
actually grounded somewhere for a while
you want to do a show and so go go check
it out on Friday
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you